Peter Charles Huffer author of past
imperfect when did you first think you
wanted to write a book about the subject
the first thing I thought was that the
Professional Division of the American
Historical Association on which I've
served for the past three years needed
to address these problems and we weren't
there were a variety of reasons why we
weren't addressing these problems but
someone needed to talk about them from
the professional side serious problems
in the doing of history were not being
discussed by professional historians who
do history for a living who've been
trained who are experts we were leaving
it to the media pundits and to the
Washington Times and The Weekly Standard
and it was totally partisan and in many
ways very uninformed so it was time to
write it so if right after these stories
began to break I began to think about it
and then when I served on the
Professional Division I developed the
strong intention of writing about it and
then the writing just came so what are
these stories you're talking about these
are the stories of some of our most
honored and justly famous historians
stephen ambrose who has been called
america's historian for good reason i
think in many ways Doris Kearns Goodwin
who was beloved historian and also very
visible face on television for example
Michael bolillo a brilliant young
historian I say young relatively
everyone that's beginning to seem young
to me now who was a neighbor of mine he
was at teaching at Emory and I teach the
University of Georgia in Athens who's
down the road fellow Georgia historians
and then Joe Ellis who in the 1990s was
among the most prolific historians and
the most honored for his work on
Jefferson which won the national book
award and then founding brothers which
won the Pulitzer Prize and they were
pilloried made their apologies but the
attack kept on going
and you know historians would do you
know media bites say this say that but
no one had really gone into the cases
tried to find out what had happened had
analyzed the text the way historians
always analyze text the way the
historians always analyze primary
sources and documents so those are the
those are the stories but there's a
backstory as well that going back to the
beginning of our nation history has been
tremendously important to us but it was
not always to get the story right this
is long before there are professional
historians the historians at the
beginning of our country's history are
ministers their publicists their editors
their politicians their their teachers
their part-time amateur historians many
of them very very fine writers and
dedicated researchers not professionals
but they knew that history had to
support the country that it had to send
a message that this experimental
Democratic Republic could survive
because the story of Republic's in
history has not been a happy one they
have risen and fallen in fact there were
old 18th century laws of how Republic's
would automatically fall so this was a
history with a partisan purpose and
history with a partisan purposed history
that spun in a certain way that leaves
out people that leaves out stories that
contradict the the message that's not
good history so there was a there's a
long history of the misuse of history
for various kinds of partisan
ideological purposes and the question
was was the history that that Ambrose
and Goodwin and Alison bolillo producing
was was did it fit into that genre of
history that was intentionally partisan
itself or was the attack on them part of
increasing partisan controversy
surrounding history starting and really
in the 1950s with historians moving in
one way or another to position
themselves during the Cold War you
mentioned the aaha what is it the
american historical association was
founded in 1884 by a group of seven
white male Protestant middle class elite
historians it was part of a movement
that was happening at the time we're
professionals began to create
professional associations American
Economic Association the American
Sociological Association also it's the
time when you get the American Bar
Association various businesses and other
professional groups are creating
associations but it's unique in many
ways because in 1889 the United States
Congress gave it a charter and that
charter told it to protect and preserve
historical documents and to watch over
to supervise the doing of history nope
the founders of the aah I had a
particular vision of history it was a
top-down vision of history history was
what great men did or what happened to
two leaders so it's a history that many
historians are not doing today it was it
was elitist it had very little use for
minorities there were no women in it for
a long long time but it has evolved it
has evolved into the umbrella
Association that is very varied very
receptive to lots of different kinds of
history and in 1974 it became a watchdog
it created the council which is elected
created the Professional Division and
after a series of plagiarism scandals in
the middle of the 1980s although
plagiarism has always been with history
historians have always faced that that
peril sometimes to come to it they
created a a kind of procedure by which
the Professional Division could hear and
adjudicate complaints and the
Professional Division heard complaints
and I think in many cases in most cases
ninety-five percent of the cases handled
them very well indeed kept
confidentiality a very careful scholarly
review
of claim and counterclaim both sides
were given a chance twice to go back and
examine documents in other words it was
what historians did providing
documentary evidence reading and
critically thinking about the
documentary evidence and then in 2003
and I have to say that a number of us in
the Association number of us on the
professional division were not happy
about this the council instructed the
Professional Division to cease hearing
cases this is hearing complaints you
know the hardest thing to do in history
the hardest thing for me to do for
example with the Ambrose and the other
cases is to provide motive even when you
get the chance to talk to people because
you have a text you have what they say
the motives were and what the council in
its official statement and the executive
director said was that we did not have
effective sanctions that is to say we
gave a letter to the parties involved
indicating what the judgment was and
they could do with it as they wished in
a handful of cases we asked the council
if they would be willing to publicize it
but in general we had no power to
sanction there was also a subtext to
that that we were afraid of lawsuits
because when you say someone is a
plagiarist or someone has in some way
carried on professional misconduct
that's slander per se they can always
find a lawyer to take that on
contingency and so on whereas the
american historical association and the
members acting in their voluntary
capacity i mean members of the pd are
not paid your elected for a three-year
term by the membership they pay your
expenses to meet and that's it how big
is the membership membership now is
almost 14,000 all historian know well in
a sense yes everyone is very interested
in history everyone reads history
everyone does history in some way we
have people who are museum curators we
have people who are a popular historian
writer
we have elementary through 12 school
teachers who are members I think that
about i looked at the membership figures
about 75% of our members are teaching
historians many colleges or universities
what do you pay a year to belong to it
um we have a sliding scale it's
voluntary you announce what you're
willing to pay it can go up to 110 120
dollars a year if you go all the way
down to twenty dollars or is it headcorn
it's headquartered not far from here 400
a street southeast how many people work
there they have a staff of about 25
people in house who runs it it's I mean
it's a it's a professional organization
it's it's paid for by the membership it
doesn't solicit grants or those kinds of
things so it's independent it's
independent doesn't take any money from
the taxpayer no you say in your book
that one that I think one of the former
presidents of the a AK Bernard Bailyn is
the greatest historian either alive or
you define it and I asked you yeah
that's what I said and if you say that
too bud vaillant and now I've called him
bud the first time in the 40 years that
I have known and respected and admired
him in his work that is the first time
that I have called him but which is his
nickname and I am I am told by others
that I am the only person the only one
of his students because I was his
graduate student from 65 to 70 and I'm
still his I'm still his student they
will tell you that I'm the only person
who hasn't called him that and I
recalled it that you had him on the show
right and I'm sure that you didn't call
him bud either I didn't know it was his
name but a Venice is but he is
remarkable why and where is he now he is
emeritus at Harvard but he's he runs
this Atlantic rim seminar and to it come
among the best and the brightest of
young people working in early American
history or Africa
history or Western European history to
gather together in fact it takes place
in the summer and it's called
colloquially camp bud because he takes
an active interest in what everyone is
doing he will he's lost nothing in terms
of his analytical ability in terms of
his ability to to put things together in
in in ways that you just don't see at
first you might not get that if you hear
him give a talk or you have him in an
interview I think he is he's shy and
given someone who's won all of those
honors I think what two or three
Pulitzer Prizes National Book Award the
banquet prize and now is sort of
commonly described as the greatest
living American historian um you have to
read his work to see all the subtlety to
see how he will take a text take a
primary source and look at it from one
side like a jeweler and then turn it and
see another facet of it and turn it and
see another facet of it and you follow
him through anything he's not an easy
person to read he's a fine stylist it's
not an easy person to read because
they're not stories and saw that popular
history its analytical intellectual
cultural history of a critical sort and
it's almost like reading Rashi you know
one of the great Jewish commentators on
Talmud you sort of have to follow it
very very carefully and the proof of its
greatness is each time you read it or in
my case each time you teach it because
I've taught it to graduate students and
I've taught undergraduate students
ideological origins voyagers and so on
going back to education in the forming
an American society and and the New
England merchants the first book that he
published i think in 65 or 64 something
like that no i'm wrong 61 something like
that way back every time you read it
every time you teach it you see
something new when did he teach you what
year from 65 to 70 in what circumstance
well he was I was a graduate student at
Hallford and he was my advisor where'd
you do your undergraduate University of
Rochester what's your expertise good
field I do early American and I do
american legal we saw you in the
classroom at the University of Georgia
what year would we see you teaching how
big with a Class B when I go back I
teach monday Wednesdays and Fridays but
I'm in my office on Tuesdays and
Thursdays and at ten o'clock you would
see me teaching the early American
history 2 235 people at 12 you would see
me in one of the amphitheaters in our
new student learning center teaching 300
students the American survey and then at
two o'clock i have an honest section and
we're doing sort of great books although
it's us technically it's a survey what
i've done is i've given them seven great
books and one of them is ideological
origins bernard balans classic from 1967
Natalie Hall is my wife where did you
meet her um she's my college roommates
kid sister she is absolutely remarkable
person what does she do she's a law
professor um she had polio as a kid she
had there was a bad batch of the live
vaccine and a number of young folks in
New York City got it she got it so with
that and the scoliosis and everything
else she got her PhD in history from
Columbia she got her JD from Georgia and
she's now a law professor at
rutgers-camden law school and for 16
years we've been married for 34 years
going on 35 and for 16 years I've been
going back and forth between Athens and
South Jersey every week I can't afford
every week every other week she's been
wonderful we have we have two two sons
and the older one is a historian at
teaching at seton hall and he also has a
law degree
also has a PhD he got the law degree and
he said I don't want to practice law he
said what do you want to do I said I
think I'll get a PhD in history they
went to Johns Hopkins and got PhD in
history and now he's teaching at Seton
Hall what is plagiarism plagiarism is
taking another person's words and
claiming them as your own now words we
know are not just words they embody
ideas formulations arguments they tell
stories they depict a certain kind of
scene we as scholars use other people's
words all the time but we are required
by the canons of our professionalism by
our ethical standards to either put
those words if they're an exact
quotation into quotation marks or to
site where we got them precisely and not
to paraphrase them so closely that in
fact we're taking the characteristic
particular forms of expression of
another person so you have you have two
ways you can go read it think about it
turn it into your own words then
indicate where you got the ideas and the
story or if you want to use those words
don't closely paraphrase and then hide
the the debt quote it put it in
quotation marks and show exactly what
you gonna do you have to quote it in the
text in the narrative or can you put it
in a footnote you can put it in a
footnote just so it's documented in the
book documented precisely in the book
for example one of the things that
people who plagiarized sometimes do is
they'll they'll take the words change
them a little bit and then when they
cite either the footnote the end nodal
wherever they'll cite a block pages as
though they would just borrow they had
read and they had thought about it and
they were using the sort of the author
of the other source as source themselves
but not really using the words whereas
in fact what they did is they took a
particular passage and they changed it a
little bit and then they hid the extent
of the dependence
what's a primary source primary source
is a document created at the time that
you're studying so for example if we're
doing early American history a primary
source might be one of the charters of
the colonies it might be a letter that a
colonist had written back to the home
country it might be a diary it might be
a law passed then it can be a printed it
can be printed it might be the
Declaration of Independence it's not
another person's book it can be in a
book from that period of time so for
example when John Adams writes his
discourses on davila or when Thomas
Jefferson writes his notes on the state
of Virginia they were later published in
book form that's okay it's the primary
sources because they're from that time
what's a secondary source it's a work by
another scholar it can be written long
ago it can be written yesterday but it's
a work by another scholar talking about
the primary sources or to telling
stories about another time in place it's
it's not a wall between primary and
secondary sources so semi permeable
membrane so that if I'm writing about
George Bancroft George Bancroft was a
very very well-known much respected
historian in the 19th century I'm
treating his books as though they were
primary sources however if I wanted to
know something that I couldn't find in a
recent book about say colonization and I
looked at Bancroft seeeeee first volume
of his history of the United States and
it talked about colonization I would be
using him as a secondary source is it
possible you know why I'm asking this
question that if somebody today got the
Bancroft prize they would not take it
and I'm really asking it because I mean
after they've read this book yeah after
they've read what I've said about that
or the hardly plagiarized sort of
casually but also hit when he's what he
stood for what he what he didn't report
what he didn't write about
yes I think that that someone could uh
who was George bankrupt George Bancroft
started I mean he p he came from the
eastern Massachusetts middle class
family was going to be a going to be a
minister he was he later became a
politician very very well known and
respected democratic politician he was a
one of our diplomats he was someone
really who represented that eastern New
England educated elite very literate
great faith however unlike many of them
in democracy but it was a particular
19th century kind of democracy it was a
democracy that left out as much as it
included now I you can say compare that
to his Federalist more conservative
eastern New England cohort and yes he's
far more liberal but there's no I mean
this has no real connection between
liberal and conservative and following
the canons of a profession and in the
19th century it was okay to borrow from
someone else to incorporate other
people's ideas footnoting was it was a
way of showing what you had read more
than a way of paying the kind of debt
that we see it is today I mean he wasn't
a professional historian although he
wrote was red and made money at it where
do you get the Bancroft prize an award
is given by Columbia University Francis
Parkman Francis Parkman is from Boston
mercantile family went to Harvard like
Bancroft most famous I think for his
first book Oregon Trail he was one of a
group of historians have actually walked
through history the most famous modern
of that kind I think so it from the
middle of the 20th century Samuel
Morrison
who actually sailed the routes that the
great Explorer sale but Parkman went out
on the trail he went out on the Oregon
Trail he met the Pawnee he met the Sioux
he wrote about them and it was a very
popular book oregon trail he was not a
healthy man he had a number of ailments
it's not clear how many of them were a
psychosomatic he had problems with his
eyes serious problems with his eyes part
of the time he actually couldn't see he
would sit in a dark room and he had a
secretary reading to him his great work
is of course a multi-volume history of
the conflict between the English and the
French for control of colonial America
and the conspiracy of pontiac which
traces that event is probably the best
known of those books where do you get
the apartment award the Parkman award is
given by the organization not the organs
I'm sorry the Society of American
Historians it's a private group it's I'm
not a member of it it's you are sort of
co-opted into it you are elected into it
by the members the money came from
another historian alan evans who was a
1920 century historian who published
many many many very very popular books
sort of to the right side of center
praising people like Rockefeller and so
on I mean it was a at the time that was
perhaps more popular among historians
but it's a grant of money that was given
for the the best written book that year
in American history you say in the book
your book that Allan Nevins was a
conservative and Harry steal kommadeur
was a liberal yes and that between the
two may published about a hundred and
sixty books yes they got possible that
70 bucks each yes it is I mean there are
people who do that people who no one has
come close to the think they both
published in the 70s or 80s richard b
Morris came close I think to their
numbers look at if you publish a
best-selling textbook that
textbook will go through like John
guarantees American nation will go
through 16 editions that 16 books right
there then if you publish collections
among those books that they publish with
collections of documents so once you've
published a successful book the textbook
publishers and the trade book publishers
are perfectly willing to cut you
contracts forward contracts for four
more books I mean I don't come close to
that now I have have to think about
about 35 36 titles and half of them are
edited works so so I'm I'm 60 years old
and I'm not not going to catch them many
of the people in your book that you
mentioned have appeared on this show
three of the people you document this
issue of both plagiarism and in Joseph
Ellis cases something else which is keep
on we've got three I got three clips and
I want to just just for identification
purpose for people who may not remember
what they look like it sound like they
all appeared about ten years ago and the
first one is stephen ambrose we were in
a hotel room out by Heathrow ready to go
i woke up at 3am when my head just flow
these stories was a little room there
wasn't any place to go I didn't want to
wake more up I went into the bathroom
sat down on the John took out a yellow
legal pad and started writing came time
to wake her up 7am I did we got dressed
got in a cab went out to the airport I'm
writing in the cab as we go out got to
the airport got checked in sat down to
have coffee I did some more writing got
on the plane flew home to the States I'm
writing the whole time as the plane
ladder in New York I had the first
chapter done it's just a little slice of
that interview talking about his writing
you write about him in what way in this
book
I come to him as one of his readers I
own Pegasus Bridge I own band of
brothers I own trying to remember the
title of the Lewis and condone tada
they're great reads you can read them in
the same with great pleasure in the
places where he wrote them it's in the
men's room at the airport I don't read
in taxicabs but they and their wonderful
stories what I'm concerned about is his
work as a scholar his work as a
professional historian I remember he he
he characterized himself and I'm sure he
did for you and for others as a
storyteller for storytellers we know the
line between fiction and truth is
blurred and that's fine each storyteller
adds to what other storytellers have
have said before but as a scholar and he
was a trained scholar with a PhD from
Wisconsin and he spent most of his
career at the University of New Orleans
as a professional historian a teacher
and a scholar there are certain rules
and we subscribe to those rules and we
teach those rules to our students and we
uphold those rules and it's what should
make us not immune to criticism but at
least deferred to and respected and when
someone like Stephen Ambrose turns out
to be a serial plagiarist which is what
he was from the beginning of his career
as a document in the book and that pulls
down the whole edifice that the rest of
us are trying to construct whereby
people respect us because we follow the
rules that we impose upon ourselves
serial pleasures first of all what year
did he die it was october two thousand
to a november the end of october two
thousand two when he died did he know
that he was being accused of being a
pleasure oh yes the the accusations had
begun at the beginning of the year and
we're in January where did the first
story about him being a plagiarist start
and how did it get there it started in
the Weekly Standard
I've never seen a print version of the
Weekly Standard I've read it online to
magazine weekly yeah yeah but owned by
Rupert Murdoch and it has a kind of
muckraker a sort of you know muckrakers
at the beginning of the 20th century
were attacking the the robber barons the
great industries for their abuses the
way they abuse their workers the way
they abused public trust and so on now
muckrakers more often than not are on
the right and they're attacking the
professionals and so on so this is a
muckraking this is a muckraking journal
but it's different from the old monkey
ligature edited by Bill Kristol yes who
has had his own journey as you know many
of us many of us have it's a generation
before my generation but that's the Sun
isn't it Irving crystals his father
Irving crystals the ones I know Bill
Kristol so this is the son Chris was a
little younger than a little younger
than me oh good I'm glad I don't want it
I don't want to age him but this was a
story that was immediately picked up see
this is what happens with the web that
you can plant a seed and because
everyone is trolling the web and because
Google and the other search engines will
pick up a term you can plant a seed in
say Horowitz's front page or something
like that and all of a sudden there are
thousand sites to it it can be picked up
you long before anyone can start to
answer a charge it has spread in a way
that direct mail or even an appearance
on TV could never spread it and this
original story written by Fred Barnes
came in what year this was like january
second 2002 so just before stephen
ambrose diet no not just before it's I
don't mean within a years yeah that's
what I mean it was it was a long and
hard year for Ambrose so where did it
come from and what was the first story
what kind of plagiarism was it was a it
was a book Ambrose had written a book
based upon George McGovern and his
cruise experience as a liberator pilot
in Europe in World War two but to fill
out the story he had used materials from
other accounts now these secondary works
they had in them primary sources in
other words the historians who had
written these had either oral histories
or had gone to documentary sources and
so on and what Ambrose did to fill out
his book is he would take the primary
sources from the other secondary sources
and put them in but not only did he take
the direct quotations from the primary
sources out of the other secondary
sources he also took the pros around
them that the other historians had
written how did he get caught it was and
as I recall the article it was an
anonymous tipster and then what the
Weekly Standard did is what we at the PD
use to do and that is parallel texts you
lay the text alongside one another and
you go back and forth and that is what i
did in the book to look at Ambrose's
work and I found not only had he taken
primary sources from the other without
citing properly in the form for citing
properly I know this sounds technical is
such and such as quoted in so you quote
the primary source Howard good no
recollections of his training as quoted
in you know wings of morning okay so
that's the form that you use but if you
want your work to see much more original
and you wanted to seem as though you'd
found that primary source yourself you
quote the primary source but you don't
say as quoted in and then if you're
going to a site two wings of morning
you'll give a block citation of a number
of pages rather than the exact page
where you took it was he doing this on
purpose you have to be doing it well you
have to be doing it knowing what you're
doing
when you say on purpose was did he see
himself as a serial plagiarist no he
denied it and persisted in denying it he
said first of all I was the first thing
that he said was I was careless I have a
big table and I have primary sources the
oral things from the Eisenhower center
of veterans recollections I have
secondary sources they're all on the
table and as I'm writing I'm going back
and forth and looking at them so in a
way the the the explanation is I was
careless and I'll make sure he said not
to be that careless again how many
people and his family worked on his
books I think there were six I'm trying
to remember these sons and daughters oh
yes this it was a family enterprise i
think it was incorporated I didn't try
to find the papers of incorporation but
one of the news stories said it was in
corporate wasn't it wasn't the sort of
facetious Ambrose ink it actually was
incorporated who wrote wings a morning
just where his main source was for all
those it is a Pennsylvania historian of
a German history yeah it's in the book
let me switch because time goes by I
want to get the second story out but we
have time to go back on some of this and
I want to show again a little clip of
Joseph Ellis talking about the American
sage a book he wrote on John Adams
here's Joseph Ellis I'm most interested
really in bringing Adams to life for a
general public while I certainly want to
have my eyes dotted in my t's crossed
and I want this to be a critical success
as a scholarly book I'm most interested
in getting it to a group of people who
are not professional stories but read
biography what are you hearing there
well this is when he made a choice his
choice was to move from pretty technical
stuff on American authors and American
culture in this period to looking at
great men
it's mainstream history Adams sells
Jefferson sells any new book on these
people will always get attention if you
go to the Smithsonian bookstore of the
museum of america american history i
went down to the bookstore and there are
all the Benjamin Franklin books that
have come out in the past three years
all of them and they're all selling the
Isaacson book and the Morgan book and
Gordon woods book and HW brands but
they're all selling there and there you
know there should be a like a Benjamin
Franklin shelf and Adam shelf of course
David McCullers book won the pulitzer
prize from biography and so there's
always and now the hamilton books are
starting to starting to come out was
Joanne Freeman at Columbia and now
what's his name challenger right and so
on they were so they're their shelves so
he's made it's made a choice that
enables him to speak to a much wider
audience he David McCullough says that
the American sage by Joseph Ellis was
one of the reasons that he wrote his jon
Hamm's book they're very different books
but it triggered his interest I mean
he's already written about Truman right
i mean it says why do you need your
interests triggered on on and it's clear
that that McCullough really likes adams
it's not clear that Ellis particularly
likes Adams what else is doing is a much
more critical kind of biography and it
was true of all of his writing about the
founding father but you don't write
about much about the John Adamson you
write about Joseph Ellis at Mount
Holyoke why well I wrote a book about
Adams and Jefferson called trying to
remember the title of my own book came
out in 83 the revolutionary generation
and it was about get a plug in for it
now it was about many of the things that
that Ellis wrote about actually didn't
compare I did not lay my text alongside
of Alice's text although we do talk
about similar things most of the time
working historians accept the fact that
other working historians kind of
professional courtesy are developing
their own ideas and using their own so
and so on Ellis was not a big cider of
other people's work secondary sources if
you go and you look at his his footnotes
even though he's writing about people
that have been written about by me least
of all by me but by many many other
scholars you find very little in the way
of secondary saucer references almost
all those references are to the original
documents the letters the papers in
usually published sometimes unpublished
collect but your original reason in here
for writing about him isn't the
plagiarism is it it's something else no
it's the fact that he he was a wonderful
storyteller about himself and some of
those stories were not true like what
did he tell oh he talked about his
service in Vietnam I don't know if he
said have been to Vietnam but he
certainly wasn't there during the
Vietnam War he spent the time at West
Point and then during the latter part of
the war he had a job at at Mount Holyoke
so he not only invented service in
Vietnam he invented combat service in
Vietnam in an elite military unit he
invented other things about his life
which are kind of extensions I mean he
was in the military he was teaching at
West Point and in uniform in military
service he he actually did help train
people to participate in the civil
rights movement but he embroided that
story sending himself through the south
as a as a putting himself in personal
peril he I mean these were these were
stories sort of with the kind of life
you'd like to have lived is Mount
Holyoke and all woman's college yeah so
he's teaching all women for how many
years telling them stories about his
service in Vietnam the way was first of
all I don't know when these stories
about Vietnam began I'm no one has
actually pinpointed that and one thing
that I I did is I treated all the
subjects that I was treating as though
they were historical subjects I didn't
pick up the phone to ask them gee
professor Ellis when did you first start
telling these stories
I think the first time he started
telling the stories those in the 1990s
some of the people that I did talk to
about other things suggest the first
time they heard them sort of before the
historical panel met before the talk
happened was in the early 1990s how did
this story of his storytelling come to
light it was a boston globe story I've
guy named journalists names of Robinson
I think water Robinson broke the story a
pretty you know I've asked about it
terrific reputation as a journalist how
did he find out tip if it hadn't been
for the tip to Walter Robinson we still
to this day would not know that those
students at Mount Holyoke were being
taught was not just mount holyoke he was
also teaching it was teaching a course
in a American culture in the Vietnam era
and he was not just teaching it at Mount
Holyoke he was also teaching you know
there's the whole group of colleges they
are in the in the valley and I think he
was also teaching in at Amherst but you
know you have you have graduate students
from you may ask who you're teaching and
and so on why did this get your
attention what why did you write about a
same problem here we are trying to
establish ourselves as authorities
because of our training because of our
intensely self-imposed professional
ethic and here's someone who's really at
the top of our profession who's honored
with all these prizes with the National
Book Award or the Pulitzer Prize who I
used to watch with great pleasure on
c-span because as you could see from
that clip he's a very engaging person to
listen to and a very very fine writer
this stuff is certainly worth worth
reading and he just sort of pulls down
the building why do you think he did it
again this is what something we began
with motive is so hard actually there
are two kinds of motives you could
supply what is the kind of arrogance I
can do this if I want it's not that no
one will catch me it's that
I have confidence in my power to to
manipulate words images I'm in front of
classes I can hold them in thrall with
these stories a kind of arrogance the
possible flip side of that is a kind of
lack of confidence in his case he really
didn't he he wasn't the combat soldier
he wasn't there on the front lines in
the civil rights movement I kind of i'm
not really the heroic character and so
on that that i could have been that
others were and now that's gone by and
I've lost that well let me reinvent
myself what happened to him um after a
period of denial by Mount Holyoke they
formed a grievance committee he agreed
to step down for a year he wasn't
teaching I believe he was deprived of
his chair I don't know whether he has it
back I know he's teaching again so after
the year and he's reviewing again for
the new york times i read a book review
of his minus x los angeles times he's
his op-ed pieces are being published
which is not so easy to do in the times
and he has a big big book coming out on
his i think it's called his excellency
from kenapa and i'm looking forward to
reading it because i read his stuff and
i enjoy his stuff would you want your
son or sons or daughters or whatever deb
being taught by him today I just have I
have two sons and William James when he
was at Johns Hopkins when he was at
Harvard Law School one of his professors
at Harvard Law School was long its tribe
and it turns out that Lawrence tribe who
we know has written many books and I
like the books and I think that they're
very authoritative may not have done all
the research or much of the research for
those books may have been done by
research assistants like William James
or the wind James was not one that's my
son William James offer he was not one
of tribes assistance but when the
research assistants do the research for
someone like tribe they also write up
their results so it may be that drive is
just the compiler and no I would not I'm
when James and I have talked about this
and how can you stand up in front of a
group of people as an author when
actually you're a compiler so I would
have told William James take someone
else for constitutional law william
james also has very very strong
standards of personal morality and
professional ethics and he was very
upset about this because he thought very
highly of trod the third one we have a
clip of his Doris Kearns Goodwin let's
watch what she had to say I do
television at home so people are much
more aware because I do local commentary
for our ABC affiliate in Boston and do a
weekly television show which I've done
for 12 years when we go on the streets
people will know me from that so the
kids are sort of queasy about getting
stopped all the time she's since that
time I was ten years ago she went on to
do MSNBC depress the Don Imus show and
things like that and as a jim lehrer
show and she no longer does the Lera
show but she's back doing the rest of
them what what went on with Doris Kearns
Goodwin well Doris Kearns Goodwin had
research assistants and those research
assistants would look at the primary
sources for her her two major books the
Fitzgeralds in the Kennedys and no
ordinary time which is a sort of a dual
biography of Eleanor and Franklin
Roosevelt in World War two huge amount
of documentary material very hard to do
20th century history I mean the amount
of material that we can look at doing
18th century history is limited when
when I do 20th century legal history
which I also do the amount of material
is so voluminous sometimes i wish i had
research assistants I don't use research
assistants on the other hand of course
my wife is also a professional historian
of a law professor my son is a and I I
often collaborate with them well her
research assistants did not make the
kinds of distinctions between primary
sources and secondary sources and
material that was being quoted in
material that was being paraphrased what
she said is what happened is that those
materials got into the book
improperly saw stand properly cited she
made a private settlement with someone
from whom she had taken a lot of
material in an integrin yes who is it
was a popular right who didn't by the
way do lots of citations and lots of no
footnotes in the book as I recall and
what Goodwin said was I apologize the
mistake is mine because my name is on
she said it was the research assistants
who had made the mistake but the mistake
is hers and she's absolutely right
because her name is on the book and she
said she learned from that experience in
the 1980s not to make the same mistake
in the 1990s but it turns out that there
are passages in no ordinary time that
have the same problem and then when that
was raised I think in the Los Angeles
Times piece would they actually start to
do side-by-side comparisons based upon
her extensive footnotes and they said
wait a second what you have here is
closed paraphrase where in fact you're
actually doing everything but quoting
someone else how did the story about
Doris Kearns Goodwin first serve tip to
weekly standard why the Weekly Standard
has not informed me of why this of why
this tip came but presumably it was
because it was on the heels of the
Ambrose story but you also give credit
to a Forbes reporter well the Forbes of
the Forbes online came in afterwards and
they started with they said in a limited
way we can't do all of these they
started to do the the parallel text
comparisons and they started to find
more and more now the problem with this
is that again
goodwin like tribe is misusing
assistance overusing assistance look
scholarship is two things it is doing
the research and it is writing it up
when you get research assistants I don't
care whether they're your family or your
friends or you pay for them or they're
your students who are in your seminar
got an A in your first year cost and
they start doing your research you're
not a scholar anymore you're sort of
running of a research corporation it's a
different kind of enterprise and then
when they start writing up their
findings and you go over it you compile
them then it's a bigger kind of
plagiarism than just the mistakes that
they're making and not putting quotation
marks are not putting the full citation
what's happened to Doris Kearns Goodwin
in all this nothing I mean I I guess
she's not on the Pulitzer Prize board
anymore I assume that that's so but
should anything happen she doesn't have
an academic affiliation nor did Ambrose
he had retired they have moved from sort
of the ranks of academic scholars into
that larger area of public intellectuals
/ popular historian so plagiarism is ok
now then of course not but how do you
how do you I mean it's not ok but it
goes on all the time the cases that we
see in my opinion from that I get a lot
of sort of quiet inquiries people send
them to me of or individuals send them
to me and we talk what we're seeing is
the tip of the iceberg now sometimes
it's casual it's momentary it's a
mistake that's been made but now you're
beginning now that we become aware of it
you're seeing many many more cases outed
architecture books which turn out to
plagiarize entire pieces of other
architecture books law professors works
that lift political scientists
earlier essays and so on so the answer
may be that the the public historians
are not going to face more scrutiny the
last story is Michael belittle belittle
yes what was it what was his book about
his book was about guns it's called
arming America it its publisher cannot
put on a huge spread for it was reviewed
in all the major trades and the reviews
were in the main the initial reviews
were glowing because what Michael
bolillo who was then a professor of
history at Emory University and the head
of a Institute on violence in America
what he had found he claimed was that
there were very few guns in early
America that's rifles as well as
handguns he went back to probate records
you saying well many things probate
records a travel accounts and so on
supposedly and he found very few guns
the the ones that he found were not in
good working order and people didn't
know how to use them and when the
militia was mustered it didn't know what
it was doing and what was called upon to
fight it fought very badly and the
importance of this argument was it
becomes part of the debate over the
Second Amendment and the original
meaning of the Second Amendment and
whether the Second Amendment talks about
a well-ordered militia or it's talking
about individual rights and gun control
and the real origin of the book i think
was an article written in the late 1980s
by a very very wonderful and brilliant
law professor at Texas named Sanford
Levinson and what Levinson said and he's
he's for gun control but what he said
was that if you read the amendment in
its context it really is about
individual rights how did we learn about
Michael ills plagiarism well no he
didn't pledge right it's not pleasure
what would you call it just may be
fabricated abrogated okay how do we
learn that um the first person to go
after him was a man and Clayton Kramer
who had been corresponding with him he
was a he was an electrical engineer I
think he was also a member of the ni
array and an advocate for NRA this is
National Rifle Association and this had
all been done online this had been much
of this had been done online they had
been working sort of the way historians
and students do Kramer was getting a
master's in history and one of the
California state schools and then but
Leo published an article in the Journal
of American history which is the leading
journal for American Historians which
sort of gave a Tracy of what the what
the first half of arming America would
look like and Kramer said you know that
doesn't sound right to me because the
the travel accounts and so on where he
says there are no guns five pages later
there are lots of guns so it sounds like
he's evidence mining which historians
sometimes do to make a point and clear
the article was making a point the book
follows from the article the book relies
and balea says he's relying upon new
evidence from probate records and the
probate records which are inventories of
a dead person's estate show very few
working firearms and this is from
colonial revolutionary early national
period well folks went back to those
probate records and they didn't find
those results at all balea was saying
fourteen percent of them sixteen percent
of them had guns in them all the old
studies Alice hands and Jones and
someone had found 45% fifty percent when
people went back to the archives the
courthouses he said he used they found
45-percent fifty percent he denied he he
claimed that he was being personally
assaulted that he was being attacked by
the NRA played a kind of shell game
whenever anyone got to close it was the
NRA who was attacking him there were
many people including the people would
originally reviewed his book people like
wonderful historians like Jack rakov and
Paul Finkleman frustrate historians who
with professional courtesy and because
they also were found the Second
Amendment argument compelling they
initially supported him
and then the support began to fall away
and Emory University reached out to the
Professional Division shortly before I
went on it and asked if we would of the
healing of the aj american historical
right and we said well our rules are you
have to make a complaint someone has to
make a complaint and then we'll hear the
case well they weren't what willing to
make a complaint so we didn't hear the
case in the end they impaneled the Blue
Ribbon group of three historians the
three historians found all the kinds of
fabrication what's more they were
unhappy with believes answers and they
said that there was serious professional
misconduct amounting to fraud Emory was
beginning to take steps against him when
he resigned saying he couldn't get a
fair hearing he is now living quietly
and privately as far as I know he has no
academic affiliation as you said that
they published the paperback version of
the book they had brought out a
paperback version in 2001 but then they
refuse to bring out a revised version in
2003 because they according to the
editor Jane Garrett at kenapa they
didn't feel that his answers to the
charges were adequate they may a simple
statement they had terminated their
relationship with him we only have less
than a minute what's how do you when you
travel through your historian community
now after you've written this book
what's the reaction to the historians
that I've spoken to they're really
intrigued by it because most of the time
we're just working so hard that we don't
have time to think about these things
I've gotten a wonderful reception from
them they seem very pleased by it the
journalists that I've talked to about
the book all focus on the charges of
misconduct so they are narrowing to
telling this one particular story and
what it means for the future of history
just as us can we do nothing this book
is called past imperfect facts fictions
fraud American history from Bancroft and
parkland to Ambrose bolillo Ellis and
Goodwin our guesses Peter Charles Huffer
University of Georgia history professor
thank you very much for joining us thank
you